ا
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول
الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى في سوره
الرعد
ودرسنا موصول
حول
تفسير
بعض ايات من سوره الرعد من كتاب
الله وقد وصلنا فيها الى قوله
تعالى افمن يعلم انما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو
اعمى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب الذين يوفون بعهد الله ولا ينقضون
الميثاق والذين يصلون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ويخشون ربهم ويخافون سوء
الحساب والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه ربهم
واقاموا الصلاه وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه ويدون بالحسنه السيئه اولئك لهم
عقب
الدار
قوله تعالى افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من
ربك
الحق ذكرنا ان العلم هنا المقصود به
العلم الشرعي العلم الذي يكون معه
العمل كمن هو اعمى
والعمى
هنا المقصود
به الكفر
والرفض
ل
رساله ورسالات الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
تعالى
انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب يعني اصحاب
العقول من هم اصحاب
العقول اصحاب العقول ق في كتاب
الله هم الذين يوفون بعهد
الله بعهد
الله اي الذي اخذ الله تعالى
عليهم حين كانوا امثال
الذر ومنه
كان ما عاهد الله سبحانه
وتعالى عباده
عليه فيما
هو محفوظ في فطرهم
ومغروم وذلك ان الانسان يعلم
بفطرته
انه عبد مخلوق مربوب وان الله خالقه واحد
سبحانه ولا يحيا ويموت عبثا لن يترك
سدا لذلك
فطرته
فانها تدفعه وتزه الى استجابه
الرسل والله عز
وجل
ذكر مثلا على الايمان المبني على كتاب
الله على الوحي حين ما
يكون ويصادف
فطره
هي
نقيه يقول تعالى نور على نور يهدي الله
لنوره من يشاء ايش نور على نور نور الوحي
على نور
الفطره والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول كل مولود يولد على الفطره
فابواه يهودانه او ينصرانه او يمجسانه
هذه العقائد فاسده ومخالفه
للفطره واما فطره الله فهو التوحيد ليس
فقط
الايمان برب
واحد
بل فهم واعتقاد ان هذا الرب ال واحد هو
الله في
السماء فوقه
متصرف له
صفات كذا
وكذا يعني بشكل عام
وكذلك
السرقه من الشر وسفك الدم من الشر والكذب
من
الشر والاحسان من الخير هذه ها الفطره
وهذا هذه الفطره
عهد لله سبحانه
وتعالى فقوله تعالى الذين يوفون بعهد الله
اي بالعهد الذي بينهم وبين الله الذي هو
عهد الفطره وكذلك
عهد عهد
الاسلام الذي يدخل في الاسلام يقوم
بالاسلام الذي يقول لا اله الا الله
فبينه وبين الله عهد
وذمه وكذلك العهد
الذي اخذ الله تعالى على عباده يوم ان
اخرجهم من ظهر ابيهم ادم عليه
السلام يقول تعالى واذ اخذ ربك من بني ادم
من ظهورهم ذريتهم واشهدهم على انفسهم الست
بربكم قالوا بلى شهدنا
ان تقولوا يوم القيامه انا كنا عن هذا
غافلين او تقولوا انما اشرك اباؤنا من قبل
وكنا ذريه من بعدهم افتهلكنا بما فعل
المبطلون
وقيل
هذا هو الفطره وقيل ايضا
انه مسح الله سبحانه وتعالى على ظهر ادم
واراه ذريته كالذر واخذ عليهم العهد كذلك
عهد الله ما يعاهد الناس
عليه فهذا
عهد عهد الله يعني الذي يعاهد الناس
و يحلف بالله او يشهد الله فهذا عهد
الله فهؤلاء اولو الالباب يوفون ب عهد
الله ولا ينقضون الميثاق النقض هو
ضد
الوثق والنقض هو حل
الشيء يقول تعالى ولا ينقضون
الميثاق
و
على
وزن
الميثاق من اجل التاكد ان هذا ميثاق غليظ
وهذا
ميثاق وثقه صاحبه فهو موثق اي محكم ربطه
وعقده فهذا
ميثاق يقول والذين يصلون ما امر الله به
ان
يوصل
يصلون
الرحم
يصلون ما امر الله به ان يوصل ما هنا عام
كل شيء امره الله تعالى ان
يوصل يصلون
الرحم يصلون
الامانات يصلون كل شيء امر الله به ان
يوصل
وكذلك ثم اشياء امر الله تعالى ان تقطع
اليس كذلك وهم يقطعون كذلك ما امر الله
بقطعه وهذا مفهوم هذا مفهوم بالمخالفه
يقول ويخشون
ربهم الخشيه وال خوف تنظر في بعض كتب
التفسير تجد مثلا ان المفسر
يقول الخشيه
الخوف هذا
كلام
تقريبي بعض الكتب تقرب
المعاني بمعنى ان الخوف
والخشيه هذه الكلمه وهذه الكلمه في لغه
العرب فانهما يشتركان في معنى لكن هذا
يفترق عن هذا في
شيء ما في ترادف تام في اللغه العرب قد
يكون في لغه غير العرب لكنه صعب جدا ان
يتصور هذا الشيء الترادف التام يعني يكون
في
كلمتين بنفس المعنى تما تماما تماما هذا
شيء صعب جدا يتصور
لماذا لان الاصوات من معاني الكلمه اليس
كذلك يعني اذا قال الانسان
مثلا
خشيه
خشيه وقال
خاف هذه
الاصوات تجعل في المستمع بل وفي
المتكلم شعورا
مختلفه لذلك الحروف
تختلف
ولذل الاص
تختلف يعني مثلا اذا قال
الانسان
المزن المن مزن يعني
السحب قال الانس
الغيم حتى في زمنا هذا الانسان يسمع المزن
والمعصراوي ويشعر باشياء مختلفه كانه ما
في ترادف
تام فايش الفرق بين الخوف والخشيه لما
تقرا في كتب التفسير تقرا مثلا خشيه او
يخشون يقول لك
يخافون هذا
الكلام
تقريبي وليس
تفصيلي وهو شان
مختصرات
التفسير فهو يقول يخشون ربهم الفرق الاهم
بين الخوف والخشيه في كتاب الله الاهم
الفرق
الاهم ان
الخوف قد يكون عن ضعف
الخائف ولكن الخشيه لا تكون الا عن عظمه
المخشي
يعني اذا انا خفت
الشيء ممكن لان الشيء يستحق الخوف و ممكن
لاني ضعيف ف الضعف في هذا الشيء الذي انا
خفته قد لا يستحق الخوف انا خفته
لضعفي فكلمه خاف
وخوف فهذا يدل عاده على نوع من
الضعف
والخشيه في المقابل هذا لا يكون
الا عن عظمه
المخشي واحد
يخشى احدا يخشى
شيئا فهذه الخشيه لا تكون الا لان هذا
الشيء عظيم يستاهل
الخوف
والفرق الثاني
الاهم ان
الخوف قد يكون عن
جهل لكن الخشيه لا تكون الا عن علم
فقط ال خاشيه لا تكون الا عن
علم
الجاهل لا يوصف بانه
يخشى بل يوصف بانه
يخاف فما وثم فروق
كثيره
لكن هذه اهم
الفروق اذا فهمنا
هذا فمثل قوله تعالى انما يخشى الله من
عباده العلماء ان الخشيه لا تكون الا من
العلم لا تكون الا
لعظمه المخشي
سبحانه لكن اذا سمعنا كلمه خوف في القران
فهو يدل على نوع من ايش من الضعف لذلك يصف
الله الملائكه
بانهم او بانها كلاهما
صحيح يخافون
ربهم يخافون طيب
الملائكه اليست عظيمه نقول نعم لكن في
مقابل الله
الملائكه ضعيفه ما في شيء
قوي بالنسبه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى هو
القهار هو الذي يضعف كل شيء دونه هو الحي
القيوم فالملائكة
فانها موصوفه في القران بماذا بالنسبه
الى
خشيتهم يخافون
ربهم يخافون ربهم فعلى كل حال قوله تعالى
ويخشون
ربهم يعني يعظمون الله ويخافون خوفا يليق
بالله خوف
ممزوج بتعظيم لا يليق الا لله سبحانه
وتعالى يخشون ربهم ما هو فقط مجرد خوف خوف
الابله مثلا الجاهل الغبي الذي
مثلا له تصورات وله لا هؤلاء يخشون ربهم
هم يخافون الله عن علم ويخ خون الله لان
الله تعالى عظيم
يخشى فهم يخشون
ربهم يقول تعالى ويخافون سوء
الحساب هنا ذكر
الخوف وهذا قد يكون من باب تغيير الالفاظ
يعني لو مثلا
قلنا ويخشون ربهم ويخشون سوء
الحساب يعني يكون في نوع
من التكرار
للفظ نفسه فاحيانا
الالفاظ تغير من
باب اللفظ تحسين اللفظ وقد يكون لهذا
معنى يقول تعالى ويخافون سوء الحساب قد
سبق ان سوء
الحساب هو الذي يك بالعدل
التام هذا سوء حساب
بالنسبه للمحاسب لانه
لم لم يدخل في رحمه الله وفضل الله وعفو
الله والانسان لا يمكن ان ينجو الا بعفو
الله فضل الله ورحمه الله وعفو
الله يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قاربوا
وسددوا وابشروا وا
انه لن يدخل احدكم الجنه
عمله قال ولا انت يا رسول الله قال ولا
انا الا ان يتغمدني الله برحمه منه وفضل
يعني الا ان يعني لا ادخل الجنه الا بعد
ان يتغمدني الله برحمه منه وفضل فهم
يخافون سوء
الحساب فالذي يخاف سوء
الحساب فهو من باب اولى
يخاف من الاعمال التي تؤدي الى سوء
الحساب فليس فقط والله انا خايف بخاف الله
لكن ما في عمل ما في ظهور لهذا
الخوف لا الذي يخ سوء الحساب والذي يخشى
ربه فلا بد لهذا الخوف ولهذه الخشيه من
ثمره يقول تعالى والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه
ربهم الصبر ابتغاء وجه
ربهم الانسان يصبر لكن
لاسباب قد يصبر الصابر لانه ضعيف ما عنده
حل غير الصبر غصبا عنه بده
يصبر وقد يصبر الصابر لان له مصلحه دنيويه
يصبر عليها
كالمتيم
لق
الذي ياتي هؤلاء بوجه وهؤلاء
بوجه
والمدلس
والمداهنة
فهذا
يصبر يصبر على اشياء لا يهواها
كثيره لكن له مصلحه
دنيويه يضحي بشرفه من اجل هذه المصلحه
ويضحي برجولته فهو متملق
ومداه ويتنازل عن كل
شيء والمنافقون في الدرك الاسفل من النار
لهذا
السبب هؤلاء
المنافقون الم يصبروا صبر بلا
صبر صبر و على
اشياء ما
كانوا
يحبونها كانوا يبغضون المؤمنين وكانوا
يبغضون النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ويكرهون
الاسلام ويحبون
الكافرين لكن
صبروا على
التخفي
لماذا لان نفوسهم
رديه
لكن قول
الالباب او اولي
الالباب يصبرون ابتغاء وجه
ربهم هم يصبرون كل صابر له
له هدف من صبره كل صبر له هدف من
صبره هؤلاء اولو
الالباب سبب
صبرهم انهم
ماذا انهم يبتغون وجه
ربهم وجه ربهم رضا ربهم سبحانه
وتعالى كقوله تعالى يخل لكم وجه ابيكم
يعني رض
ابيكم فله سبحانه
وتعالى كان له وجه الله يعني كانه رض الله
سبحانه وتعالى فهم يصبرون لانه يقربهم الى
الله لا غير هذا هو
السبب و
نكتفي بهذا القدر ان شاء الله والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
ي الله سبحانه وتعالى 19
20ه الر 1
قران الله سبحانه وتعالى
transat is the one who knows that that
which has s been s down upon you from
your lord the truth the one who is
blind rather it is mer the people of
intellect who will
remember and ‏what me here by
remembering is not
just remembering some information that
is by remembering is what comes as of
true remem which is implementation a
person
الله سبحانه
وتالى areed of the
of
‏and so الله سبحانه
وتالى men the believer is not the
disbeliever just the blind and the
one who can see are not the same they
couldn't be more
different the blind is the very
antithesis of the person who can
see and likewise the believer and the
disbeliever
قران because sometimes people forget
this when they go out into the real
world and
they start to overlook things this
there is a difference there will always
be a
difference and the whoever and
dis
محد صل الله عليه
وسلم
diff سبحانه
وتعالى
‏mind
areen
of and they do
not they do not
withdraw
against سبحه وتى
الله قران بي اسرايل ff my coven and i
shall ff
yours likewise the coven
of
‏wi
also and these people do
not withdraw
their he
says continuing in defining the features
the most prominent features of the
people of true
intellect intellect here meaning int is
consequence a person who super
‏iq
all however
to
to ob
allah or to driven by ego to ob a they
might as have zero intellect because it
was no consequence yeah it will be
consequence here in world for a few
minut
‏they may be able to build a few things
they may be able to discover a few
things or whatever it is that people you
know look up to as being the goals of
of
intellect but at the end of the day all
of these things go right back into the
box and all of these buildings and all
of these things that we as human beings
beat our chest
about are just little specs in space
‏it's that's all it is the only thing
significant about the human being is
obedience
toite of adversity intellect of the
human being free will and
so allah سبحانه وتعالى mention here the
people of intellect me the people whom
int was
ofe mean
int
‏i this is what my position here in this
world is and they follow that someone
who gets distracted easily and someone
who is not filling
that
in he say and those
who all
‏be
with and they fear their lord based on
knowledge and they fear the greatness of
their
lord and they
fear po
judgment meaning on the day of judgment
they fear that they will be poorly
judged
jud to
الله سبحانه
وتالى
never evil judgment or an oppressive
judgment or a poor
judgment the outcome of his judgement
may be for the
recipient the
judged jg
‏here is
indiv who is to account and not forgiven
by allah person who held to account for
everything that they did they will not
survive that
jud they will sur
be punished by allah the صل الله عليه
وسلم
‏par said not even you messenger of he
said not even
myself i not ent paradise
until
allah envel me in his paron and
mercy and so these indiv
they ‏fear a bad jud mean a jud the
result of which will be for them and
reflect negatively upon their
eternity because they were not given any
slack they didn't deserve it they didn't
ask allah سحانه وى for it and these are
the kind of people that
slack only ens in evil they don't see it
as being you know
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان شا الله الله اعلم صلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله
[Silence]
ا
ان